à l'ats péter haas le timon somaro
teigneux c'était gai type e bay koko la
tombe d'un paysage sa la pa nourizad non
la corde so they ça fait sens à la rose
est profané 25 ans après sa mort ses
chansons font toujours vivre et le corps
des réunionnais alain peters est et
restera une figure emblématique de notre
patrimoine culturel dresse la maloja
paniers sur la tête kalou badia
l'artiste part aux engagés à laisser une
marque indélébile dans l'histoire
musicale locale
preuve de son talent hors norme l'oeuvre
du chanteur paraboles heures à suis
traversé les générations
il reste toujours aussi populaire sa
musique est continue passant à djoko ci
est chanté par les jeunes et moins
jeunes et c est pas donner un toit de sa
réunion n'est pas donné on pense que
même demain si mon enfant et voyez coûte
encore les pick n y pense que ce sera
combien fait souvenir en nous des choses
nous dit eh ben voilà c'est quelqu'un
c'est l'emblème de la réunion dommages
et la proximité me pense qu'il ya
beaucoup apporté à la à la musique à la
réunion c'est un vrai réunionnais un
vrai trésor
il a voulu vraiment représenter la
réunion c'est un génie vraiment le bull
avait vraiment des qualités de potentiel
loin pour la musique réunionnaise
enjimmi un magicien les qualificatifs ne
manquent pas pour parler d'alain peters
gilbert pounia le leader du groupe
ziskakan et l'un de ses amis d'enfance
ils se sont rencontrés à l'école et a
toujours été drôle le monde amis depuis
très très jeune et donc le dialogue avec
tous les musiciens balle parce qu'il
faut pas oublier que la vitesse c'est le
musicien balle à la base il ya eu
beaucoup dans les bals ici à la réunion
parce que à l'époque c'était pas les
cons c'est tout ça mais comme le concert
nous quoi alain peters avait joué avec
les mots il composait en créole un
mélange rare de blues et de maloya
imprégné hocine influences rock et de
ses gars
un artiste d'une influence majeure pour
gilbert pounia blessures que pau j'en ai
plein de générations et de différents
pays
les chansons dans les mélodies tout ça
c'est des références c'est vraiment à
non pas douter les chansons d'un à
peters continueront longtemps encore
d'être fredonnées par les réunionnais
[Musique]